it's weird how the BLM riots following
the death of George Floyd have just been
completely memory hold you never hear
anybody mention them we remember however
and we have the video so in June of 2020
BLM Riders were destroying the city of
St Louis which is a great City didn't
need to be knocked around any more than
it already has been but that's what they
were doing burning things around two in
the morning a 77 year old retired police
captain called David Dorne was alleged
to a burglar alarm that went off at a
friend's pawn shop so he showed up to
investigate like a good citizen when he
arrived he was murdered
you almost never hear his name BLM never
mentions it now neither do the huge
companies that have paid for BLM and of
course the media has ignored it but the
trial of the man who is believed to be
the killer a guy called Stephen Cannon
just began this week and we thought it
was a perfect time to speak to Captain
David Dorn's Widow and who joins us
tonight Mr Jordan thank you so much for
coming on
um and I and it's got to be awful for
you do you think just to just to the to
what's going on right now first do you
think the man accused of your husband's
murder will be brought to Justice
I'm praying I'm gonna have
um I'm trying to have faith in the
justice system
good well I I hope it's well placed I I
have to ask because I can't resist this
didn't happen in a vacuum these riots
were paid for by the biggest companies
in the United States all of whom seem to
have escaped criticism why does nobody
mention that this was all financed by
Corporate America do you think
um I'm not sure
um you know it's the woke community that
is funding them not only just these
corporations but celebrities and
athletes across the country are are
funding them just blindly funding this
misguided
um
agenda
well it's certainly
affected you and derailed your life your
husband was murdered what would you what
would you say to them I don't think
they've had to confront the human cost
of what they paid for
no and it's just not me there's other
widows out there you know of law
enforcement you know black lives matter
called for the death of police and
nobody's done anything about it you know
define demean and kill police officers
across the country and
um you know we're the enemy now when
it's not
um
when we're not it's you know there's
other factors involved but we seemed you
know the police seem to be the easy
Target and um nobody's standing up for
their rights
yeah and I mean these are people I mean
did your husband get rich in law
enforcement does anybody get rich in law
enforcement
no neither of us did I did 28 years as
well and neither one of us got rich in
this and um we don't we don't become
police officers to become rich we become
police officers because we have it's a
calling just like it is it's calling to
become
um a priest or a calling to become a
doctor it's in our blood it's what we
want to do
so as you pointed out BLM was calling
for the murder of police officers back
during the Obama Administration you know
fry like bacon pigs in a blanket fry
like bacon I mean that that video was on
Fox News I no one at the just Department
did anything about that
no they didn't and they were you know
they were burning down cities and they
were calling it peaceful protests and
there's nothing peaceful about it
this must having suffered as you have
this must
this must drive you crazy
it does you know and now having to sit
through a trial of a man who's accused
of killing my husband
um when the the riot was funded and
organized by black lives matter and all
these corporations
yeah well I'm I'm sorry to I know you're
being dragged through this uh already
but I I think it's important to see the
faces of the people who've suffered and
you're certainly one of them so I'm
grateful that you came on today andorn
thank you
thank you and if anybody wants to know
more about you know these corporations
they can go to
www.concerncommunities.org forward slash
pledge it's a group of black clergy
who've got together to um stand up to
these vote corporations athletes and
celebrities
I've actually done that and there's a
video on that site that's so
unbelievable and I hope that everyone
watching tonight will go see that video
it it wrecked my day but in a good way
anyway andoran thank you very much yes
thank you sir subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight